Me gustaría empezar con una observación,
que es que si he aprendido algo en el último año,
es que la ironía mas grande
de publicar un libro sobre la lentitud
es que tienes que ir promocinándolo muy rápidamente.
Estos días parece que paso la mayor parte de mi tiempo
corriendo de ciudad en ciudad, estudio en estudio,
entrevista en entrevista,
presentando el libro a pedacitos.
Porque todo el mundo hoy en día
quiere saber cómo frenar,
pero quiere saberlo de manera muy rápida. Entonces...
el otro día estuve en CNN
y pasé más tiempo en maquillaje que hablando en el aire.
Y yo creo que -- eso no es tan sorprendente, ¿no?
Porque ese es más o menos el mundo en que -- vivimos ahora,
un mundo atascado en avanzar rápidamente.
Un mundo obsesionado con la rapidez,
con hacer todo más rápido, con embutir más y más
en menos tiempo.
Cada momento del día se siente como
una carrera contrarreloj.
Tomando prestada una frase de Carrie Fisher, la cual --
está en mi biografía, así que la diré de nuevo --
"En estos días hasta una gratificación momentánea lleva mucho tiempo."
Y
si piensan en cómo intentamos mejorar las cosas, ¿qué hacemos?
¿Las apuramos, no? Antes marcábamos, ahora marcamos con un solo botón.
Solíamos leer; ahora hacemos lectura rápida. Solíamos caminar; ahora caminamos rápidamente.
Y por supuesto, solíamos tener citas y ahora tenemos citas rápidas.
Incluso las cosas que son por naturaleza lentas --
también tratamos de acelerarlas.
Hace poco estaba en Nueva York, y pasé por un gimnasio
que tenía un anuncio en la ventana de un curso nuevo, de tarde.
Y era de, adivinen, yoga rápido.
La solución perfecta para profesionales con hambre de tiempo
que quieren saludar al sol
pero solo quieren ceder 20 minutos para ello.
Estos son ejemplos un tanto extremos,
y son divertidos y buenos para reírse.
Pero hay algo serio,
y creo que en esa precipitada carrera del día a día,
a menudo no vemos el daño
que nos hace este vivir a la carrera.
Esta cultura rápida se nos infiltra de tal manera
que casi no percibimos cómo afecta
a cada aspecto de nuestras vidas.
Nuestra salud, nuestra dieta, nuestro trabajo,
nuestras relaciones, el medio ambiente y nuestra comunidad.
Y a veces necesitamos --
una llamada de atención, ¿no? --
que nos advierta de que vivimos nuestras vidas con prisa
en vez de vivirlas realmente; de que estamos
viviendo la vida rápido, en vez de vivirla bien.
Y creo que para mucha gente, esta advertencia
toma forma de enfermedad.
Por ejemplo, agotamiento, o cuando el cuerpo dice,
"No puedo más," y tira la toalla.
O quizás una relación se esfuma
porque no hemos tenido el tiempo, o la paciencia,
o la tranquilidad,
para estar con la otra persona, para escucharla.
Y mi llamada de atención llegó cuando comencé
a leerle cuentos a mi hijo por la noche,
y me di cuenta de que al final del día,
iba a su cuarto y no podía reducir la velocidad,
y leía muy velozmente "El gato en el sombrero."
Me salteaba algunas líneas por aquí,
párrafos por allá, a veces una página entera,
y por supuesto, mi pequeño conocía perfectamente el libro, así que peleábamos.
Y lo que debía haber sido el momento más relajante, más íntimo,
el momento más tierno del día,
cuando un padre se sienta a leerle a su hijo,
se convirtió en una especie de lucha entre gladiadores;
un choque entre su velocidad y mi --
o, mi velocidad y su lentitud.
Y esto continuó por algún tiempo,
hasta que me encontré ojeando un artículo del diario
con consejos para gente rápida sobre cómo ahorrar tiempo.
Y uno de ellos hacía referencia a una serie de libros llamados
"El cuento de un minuto."
Ahora me estremezco diciendo esas palabras,
pero entonces mi primera reacción fue muy diferente.
Mi primera reacción fue decir,
"Aleluya -- ¡qué genial idea!
Esto es justo lo que estoy buscando para acelerar aún más la hora de acostarse."
Pero por suerte,
se me encendió la lamparita, y mi siguiente reacción fue muy diferente,
y retrocedí, y pensé,
"¡Para! -- ¿realmente hemos llegado aquí?
¿Estoy realmente en un apuro tal que soy capaz
de engañar a mi hijo con un resumen al final del día?"
Y entonces dejé el diario --
y estaba por tomar un avión -- y me quedé sentado allí,
e hice algo que no había hecho por mucho tiempo -- y es no hacer nada.
Solo pensé, y pensé durante un buen rato.
Y cuando me bajé del avión, había decidido que quería hacer algo al respecto.
Quería investigar esta cultura de la carrera,
y lo que me estaba haciendo a mí y al resto. Y yo --
Tenía dos preguntas en mi cabeza.
La primera, ¿cómo nos volvimos tan rápidos?
Y la segunda, ¿es posible,
o incluso deseable, frenar?
Ahora, si piensan en cómo
nuestro mundo se aceleró tanto, surgen los sospechosos de siempre.
Ustedes piensan en la urbanización,
el consumismo, el lugar de trabajo, la tecnología.
Pero creo que si miran a través de esas fuerzas
llegan a lo que podría ser la razón más profunda,
la esencia de la pregunta,
y es cómo percibimos el tiempo en sí.
En otras culturas el tiempo es cíclico.
Lo ven como moviéndose en grandes
círculos sin apuro.
Siempre se está renovando y refrescando.
Mientras que en Occidente, el tiempo es lineal.
Es un recurso finito,
siempre se está escurriendo.
O lo usas o lo pierdes.
El tiempo es dinero, como dijo Benjamin Franklin.
Y pienso en lo que eso nos hace psicológicamente,
crea una ecuación.
El tiempo es escaso, entonces ¿qué hacemos?
Bueno, aceleramos, ¿no?
Tratamos de hacer más y más con menos y menos tiempo.
Transformamos cada momento de cada día
en una carrera hacia la meta.
Una meta que, por cierto, nunca alcanzamos.
pero una meta al fin y al cabo.
Y creo que la pregunta es,
¿es posible liberarse de ese pensamiento?
Y por suerte, la respuesta es sí, porque
lo que descubrí, cuando empecé a mirar alrededor, es que hay
una reacción global contra esta cultura que
nos dice que más rápido es siempre mejor, y que más ocupado es mejor.
Al otro lado del mundo, la gente está haciendo lo impensable:
están frenando, y descubriendo que
aunque la sabiduría convencional les dice que si desaceleran los aplastarán,
lo contrario resulta ser cierto.
Desacelerando en los momentos correctos,
las personas descubren que hacen todo mejor.
Comen mejor, hacen el amor mejor, se ejercitan mejor,
trabajan mejor, viven mejor.
Y en esta mezcla de
momentos, lugares, y actos de desaceleración,
yace lo que muchas personas ahora llaman
el Movimiento lento internacional.
Ahora, si me permiten un pequeño acto de hipocresía,
les mostraré brevemente lo que --
lo que está sucediendo en el Movimiento lento. Si piensan en comida,
muchos habrán escuchado del Movimiento de la comida lenta.
Comenzó en Italia, pero se ha expandido por el mundo,
y ahora tiene 100.000 integrantes
en 50 países.
Y es motivado por un mensaje muy simple y sensato,
que es que obtenemos más placer y más salud
de nuestra comida cuando
la cultivamos, cocinamos y consumimos a un ritmo razonable.
Y piensen también en la explosión del
movimiento del cultivo orgánico, y el renacer de las ferias de granjeros,
es otro -- son otros ejemplos
del hecho de que las personas están ansiosas por liberarse
de la comida, la cocina y el cultivo de su comida
en forma industrial.
Quieren regresar a los ritmos más lentos.
Y a partir del Movimiento de la comida lenta surgió algo
llamado el Movimiento de las ciudades lentas, que comenzó en Italia,
pero se ha esparcido por y más allá de Europa.
Y en esto, las ciudades
comienzan a replantearse cómo organizan su espacio,
y entonces a la gente se le anima a desacelerar
y oler las rosas y conectarse con los demás.
Podrían detener el tránsito,
o poner un banco de plaza, o algunos espacios verdes.
Y de cierto modo, estos cambios resultan más que la suma de sus partes,
porque cuando una Ciudad lenta se vuelve una Ciudad lenta oficialmente,
es como una declaración filosófica.
Le está diciendo al resto del mundo y a la gente en esa ciudad,
que creemos que en el siglo 21,
la lentitud tiene un rol importante.
En medicina, creo que mucha gente está muy desilusionada
con la mentalidad de la cura rápida
que se encuentra en la medicina convencional.
Y millones alrededor del mundo se mueven hacia
formas de medicina alternativa y complementaria,
que tienden a inclinarse por
maneras de curar más lentas, más suaves e íntegras.
Ahora, obviamente este tipo de terapias complementarias están a prueba,
y yo personalmente dudo que el café por enema
sea públicamente reconocido alguna vez.
Pero otros tratamientos
como acupuntura y masajes, e incluso sólo la relajación,
claramente tienen algún tipo de beneficio.
Y médicos colegas de primera categoría están
empezando a estudiar estas cosas para averiguar cómo funcionan,
y qué podríamos aprender de ellas.
Sexo. Hay una enorme cantidad de sexo rápido por ahí, ¿no?
Estaba corriendo --
bueno -- aquí no hay juego de palabras.
Estaba corriendo lentamente rumbo a Oxford,
y pasé por un kiosco, y vi una revista,
una revista de hombres, y decía en la portada,
"Cómo hacer que tu pareja tenga un orgasmo en 30 segundos."
Ya ven, hasta el sexo
está cronometrado estos días.
Ahora,
a mí me gusta un rapidito tanto como a cualquiera,
pero creo que hay mucho que ganar
del sexo lento -- de desacelerar en el dormitorio.
Te aprovechas de esas
corrientes psicológicas, emocionales, espirituales
y con el calentamiento obtienes un mejor orgasmo.
Digamos que puedes sacarle más provecho.
Las Hermanas Pointer lo dijeron más elocuentemente, ¿no?
cuando cantaban los elogios a un amante con la mano lenta.
Ahora, todos nos reíamos de Sting
hace unos años cuando se inclinó por el tantra,
pero unos años más tarde, encontramos parejas de todas las edades
acudiendo en masa a talleres, o quizás simplemente
en sus propios dormitorios, buscando la forma
de poner los frenos y tener mejor sexo.
Y por supuesto, en Italia, donde -- los italianos parecen saber siempre
dónde encontrar el placer,
han lanzado un movimiento oficial de Sexo lento.
Los lugares de trabajo,
en muchos lugares del mundo --
siendo Norteamérica una notable excepción --
las horas de trabajo han ido disminuyendo.
Y Europa es un ejemplo de ello.
Las personas descubren que su calidad de vida mejora
a medida que trabajan menos, y también
que aumenta su productividad por hora.
Ahora, está claro que la semana laboral
de 35 horas en Francia tiene problemas --
demasiado, demasiado pronto, demasiado rígidamente.
Pero otros países de Europa, notablemente los países nórdicos,
están demostrando que es posible
tener una economía brillante
sin ser fanático del trabajo.
Y Noruega, Suecia,
Dinamarca y Finlandia ahora están
entre las seis naciones más competitivas de la tierra,
y trabajan la cantidad de horas que haría que un americano medio
llorara de envidia.
Y si van más allá del nivel nacional,
hacia el nivel de una micro empresa,
más y más empresas se están dando cuenta
de que deben permitir que sus empleados
trabajen menos horas o que puedan desenchufarse --
un recreo al mediodía, ir a sentarse a una sala tranquila,
apagar sus Blackberrys -- tú, al fondo --
sus teléfonos celulares,
durante el día de trabajo o los fines de semana, para que tengan
tiempo de recargar y para que el cerebro entre
en un estado de creatividad.
Y sin embargo en estos días no son sólo
los adultos quienes trabajan de más; los niños también, ¿verdad?
Tengo 37 años, y mi niñez finalizó a mediados de los 80,
y veo a los niños ahora, y me asombra cómo
corren con más tarea,
más tareas con tutores y extracurriculares,
de lo que nos podríamos haber siquiera imaginado hace una generación.
Y algunos de los correos más desgarradores
que recibo a través de mi sitio web
son de adolescentes
a punto de llegar al agotamiento, rogándome que escriba
a sus padres,
para ayudarlos a desacelerar, para ayudarlos a bajarse de
esta rutina a todo gas.
Pero por suerte hay una reacción también de los padres,
y están descubriendo que las ciudades de los Estados Unidos
se estan uniendo y prohibiendo las tareas extracurriculares
en un día particular del mes, de manera que la gente pueda
aflojarse y tener un poco de tiempo con la familia, y desacelerar.
La tarea es otro tema. Están surgiendo prohibiciones
contra la tarea en todo el mundo desarrollado,
en escuelas donde durante años se había ido apilando más y más tarea,
y ahora están descubriendo que menos puede ser más.
Hubo un caso en Escocia hace poco
donde un colegio privado de alto rendimiento académico
prohibió la tarea
para todos los menores de 13 años,
y los padres de alto rendimiento enloquecieron y dijeron,
"Qué haces, nuestros hijos fracasarán" -- y el director dijo,
"No, no, sus hijos necesitan desacelerar al final del día."
Y justo este último mes llegaron los resultados,
y en matemática, ciencia, las notas subieron un 20 por ciento
de media en el último año.
Y creo que lo que es muy revelador es que
las universidades de élite, citadas a menudo como la razón
por que la gente empuja y presiona tanto a sus hijos,
se están dando cuenta de que la calidad de los estudiantes
que llegan está decayendo. Estos niños tienen notas espectaculares,
tienen CVs repletos de tantas extracurriculares,
que te harían llorar.
Pero les falta chispa, carecen
de la habilidad de pensar creativamente,
no saben soñar. Y entonces estas universidades de la liga Ivy,
y Oxford, Cambridge, etc, estan empezando a transmitir a padres
y estudiantes el mensaje de que necesitan frenar un poco.
Y en Harvard, por ejemplo, enviaron
una carta a los estudiantes -- de primer año --
diciéndoles que sacarían más provecho de la vida, y de Harvard,
si frenaban. Si hacían menos,
pero dándole tiempo a las cosas, el tiempo que necesitan,
para disfrutarlas, saborearlas.
E incluso si a veces no hacían nada en absoluto.
Y a esa carta la llamaron -- muy revelador, yo creo --
"¡Frenen!" -- con un signo de exclamación al final.
Entonces, adondequiera que miren, me parece que el mensaje es el mismo.
Que menos es muy a menudo más,
que más lento es muy a menudo
mejor. Pero, dicho esto, por supuesto,
no es tan fácil desacelerar, ¿verdad?
Escucharon que recibí una multa por exceso de velocidad
mientras estaba investigando para mi libro sobre los beneficios de la lentitud,
y eso es verdad, pero eso no es todo.
Yo estaba yendo para una cena
ofrecida entonces por el movimiento Comida lenta.
Y por si eso no fuera lo suficientemente vergonzoso, me multaron en Italia.
Y si alguno de ustedes alguna vez condujo en una autopista italiana,
sabrán bien lo rápido que iba.
(Risas)
Pero, ¿por qué es tan difícil frenar?
Creo que hay varias razones.
Una es que -- la velocidad es divertida -- es sexy.
Es una descarga de adrenalina. Es difícil dejarlo.
Creo que hay una especie de dimensión metafísica --
que la velocidad se vuelve una manera de aislarnos
de las preguntas más grandes y profundas.
Nos llenamos de distracciones, nos ocupamos,
así no tenemos que preguntarnos,
¿estoy bien?, ¿soy feliz?, ¿mis hijos están creciendo bien?,
¿Están los políticos tomando buenas decisiones por mí?
Otra razón -- aunque creo que quizás es la razón más poderosa --
de por qué se nos hace tan difícil frenar, es el tabú cultural
que hemos erigido en contra de frenar.
Lento es una palabra mala en nuestra cultura.
Es sinónimo de holgazán, vago,
de ser alguien que se rinde.
"Él es un poco lento" es en realidad sinónimo
de ser -- de ser estúpido.
Yo creo que el Movimiento Lento -- el propósito del Movimiento lento,
o su principal objetivo, es derribar ese tabú,
y decir que -- que sí,
a veces lento no es -- la respuesta,
que existe tal cosa como "lentitud mala."
Que -- hace poco me quedé trancado en la M25,
una carretera de circunvalación en Londres,
y me pasé 3 horas y media ahí. Y les puedo decir
que eso sí es lentitud mala.
Pero la nueva idea,
el tipo de idea revolucionaria del Movimiento lento,
es que también existe la lentitud buena.
Y la lentitud buena es tomarse el tiempo
para comer con sus familias, con el televisor apagado.
O -- tomarse el tiempo para mirar un problema desde todos los ángulos
en la oficina para poder tomar la mejor decisión
en el trabajo.
O incluso simplemente tomarse el tiempo
para desacelerar
y saborear sus vidas.
Ahora, una de las cosas que encuentro más motivante
de todo esto que está sucediendo alrededor del libro
desde que salió, es la reacción hacia él.
Y sabía que cuando mi libro sobre la lentitud saliera,
iba a ser bienvenido por la brigada de la Nueva Era,
pero también ha sido aceptado, con mucho gusto,
por el mundo corporativo -- ya saben,
la prensa de negocios, pero también,
por grandes empresas y organizaciones de liderazgo.
Porque la gente en la cima, las personas como ustedes, creo,
están comenzando a darse cuenta de que hay mucha
velocidad en el sistema,
hay mucha ocupación, y es momento de encontrar,
o volver, a ese arte perdido de cambiar de marcha.
Otra señal alentadora, creo,
es que no es sólo en el mundo desarrollado
donde esta idea está siendo aceptada. En el mundo en desarrollo,
en países que están a punto de dar ese salto
hacia el primer mundo -- China, Brasil,
Tailandia, Polonia, etc --
esos países están -- han acogido la idea del Movimiento lento,
muchas personas en ellos, y se ha generado un debate
en los medios de comunicación, en las calles.
Porque creo que están mirando a occidente, y están diciendo,
"Bueno, nos gusta ese aspecto de lo que tienen,
pero no estamos tan seguros de eso otro."
Entonces, dicho todo eso,
¿es posible?
Esa es hoy la principal pregunta ante nosotros. ¿Es posible
desacelerar? Y yo --
Yo estoy feliz de poder decirles
que la respuesta es un sí rotundo.
Y me presento como la Muestra A,
una especie de adicto a la velocidad
rehabilitado.
Todavía amo la velocidad. Vivo en Londres,
y trabajo como periodista,
y disfruto del barullo y el estar ocupado,
y de la adrenalina que se obtiene de ambas cosas.
Juego al squash y al hockey sobre hielo,
dos deportes muy rápidos, y no los dejaría por nada del mundo.
Pero también, durante el último año,
he tomado contacto con mi tortuga interna.
(Risas)
Y lo que eso significa es que
yo no -- yo ya no me
sobrecargo injustificadamente.
Mi modo por defecto es no ser nunca más
un adicto a la velocidad.
Ya no escucho al
carruaje alado del tiempo acercarse,
o por lo menos no tanto como antes.
En realidad ahora puedo escucharlo, porque veo que mi tiempo pasa.
Y el resultado de todo esto es que
en realidad me siento mucho más feliz, más sano,
más productivo que nunca.
Siento que estoy viviendo
mi vida en vez de correr por ella.
Y quizás la más importante
medida del éxito de esto
es que siento que mis relaciones son mucho más profundas,
más ricas, más fuertes.
Y para mí, creo, la prueba de fuego
de si esto funcionaría, y lo que significaría,
siempre iba a ser los cuentos nocturnos, porque ahí fue donde
el viaje comenzó. Y ahí las noticias son
color de rosa también.
Al final del día voy al cuarto de mi hijo.
No llevo puesto el reloj. Apago la computadora,
así no escucho el correo eletrónico que llega,
y freno hasta llegar a su ritmo y -- y leemos.
Y como los niños tienen su propio tempo, su reloj interno,
ellos no aprovechan el tiempo
porque hayas programado 10 minutos para ellos.
Necesitan que te muevas a su ritmo.
Descubrí que a los 10 minutos de empezar un cuento,
mi hijo de repente dirá, "Sabes qué,
hoy pasó algo en el recreo que me molestó mucho."
Y entonces cambiamos de tema y conversamos sobre eso.
Y ahora me doy cuenta de que los cuentos
solían ser una especie de --
algo en mi lista de cosas que hacer, algo terrible,
porque era tan lento y tenía que terminarlo rápidamente.
Se ha convertido en mi recompensa al final del día,
algo que realmente -- realmente aprecio.
Y tengo una especie de final de Hollywood
para mi charla de esta tarde,
que dice más o menos así.
Hace unos meses, me estaba preparando para iniciar
otra gira de mi libro, y tenía mis valijas empacadas.
Estaba abajo en la puerta de mi casa esperando un taxi,
y mi hijo vino bajando por las escaleras y había
hecho una tarjeta para mí. Y la traía.
Había grapado dos tarjetas, muy parecidas a estas,
y había puesto un sticker adelante de su
personaje favorito, Tintín, al frente.
Y me dijo,
o me lo entregó y yo leí,
y decía, "Para papi, te quiero, Benjamin."
Y pensé, "Aah, esto es muy dulce,
¿es una tarjeta de buena suerte para la gira del libro?"
Y el dijo, "No, no, no, papi -- esta tarjeta es
por ser el mejor lector de cuentos del mundo."
Y pensé, "Sí, esto de frena ... "
Muchas gracias.